[Music]
just a slight disclaimer you know how
much i love disclaimers if our voices
sound slightly muffled it's because we
are wearing masks they might not sound
muffled but yeah they do a little bit
one of us his name rhymes with tischen
has been exposed potentially to uh the
new omicron variant i don't know why i
said it so pleasantly
but yes there's a chance yeah no fault
of my own no i may have been exposed to
copenhagen so she shouldn't be laughing
austin and i are being extra cautious
yeah but i'm sure it's fine
okay speaking of being extra cautious i
once tentatively asked out a lady
in high school was the first time i ever
officially asked someone out on a date i
think i had recently got my license i
was 16 then i asked out a lady that i
was thought was very cute named jesse
we worked at the same coffee shop we did
summer theater i mean it was the stars
that aligned long story very short i was
very late picking her up like
embarrassingly late i think like an hour
maybe later
she did and she should
you know it kept coming up throughout
the day it was kind of like i don't
think she was able to get past it on the
date and then i think it was the nail in
the coffin for me i think i was already
in the coffin i don't think she was that
crazy to go out with me it was a
learning experience and you've never
been late since that's right i've
completely changed my ways since then
no i didn't it's taken me a long time
i've struggled with uh
being prompt and responsibilities being
on time and i hope i'm better at it
let's probably start the show that's
right right now
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short and i
am your better with time management host
justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
don't you don't think
i think i am well as long as you think
you are and that's what that's what
matters
i'm better i didn't say i was good at it
okay and my more prompt punctual co-host
brother christian i am definitely more
punctual than you yes and in fact you
just pointed out before we started
recording that we have 31 minutes until
the jets game starts
so that is case in point so this has to
be efficient yes which is good it's we
have a little fire under our asses it's
good to be efficient even more so in
this particular episode because i have a
feeling our guest would appreciate yes
us being efficient yes wouldn't you say
wouldn't you guess i would guess that i
think he would agree with that and um i
i was so wanted to get to know this guy
i'm so glad i did and i can't wait for
you to hear it christian and i have been
really obsessed with this show on
netflix called love on the spectrum it's
a dating show on which the people they
profile are on the spectrum or on the um
you know to varying degrees on the
spectrum and uh they're just the
sweetest loveliest people and uh the
reason we're talking about dating and
it's slightly awkward first dates is
because our guest today is i think the
standout from the show
uh the very charming uh michael theo if
you watch the show of course you know
who he is it's one of those if you know
you know situations oh yeah and if you
don't know you should know you should do
yourself a huge favor and check out love
on the spectrum it's the second season
came out a few months ago so there's
been two seasons now and i think there's
about what six epis six episodes each
and it is
i can't really say enough about it it is
one of the most compelling certainly the
most compelling reality show i've ever
seen oh easily it's kind of like the
opposite of what the bachelors become
because the bachelor they're so aware of
the cameras and the
the the potential for being famous and
the currency that being on camera on tv
has and uh the people profiled on love
on the spectrum are the opposite they
don't seem they seem completely and
purely
driven to just find love it's beautiful
to watch it's really like it's one of
those rare combinations of like really
funny moments but heartbreaking and
really inspiring stuff on it it's just
beautiful human drama and comedy and um
again we just still love the people they
profile takes place in australia
so they're all australian people on the
spectrum and
yeah i think i agree michael is
to me the most compelling figure on the
show and his family
is incredible and he has such a
wonderful relationship with them so
if you haven't watched the show
um
that there is some context but again i
think we both highly recommend checking
it out it's not much of a time
commitment and it's uh it's one of those
shows where you'll in the span of 40
minutes you'll
likely
laugh a lot and cry a lot and it's very
moving and very funny and just like one
of the best things we've seen and what
would you say about michael is that his
he's he's particularly driven to find
love it's been a compelling pursuit of
his would you say there's something
about the idea of finding love for
michael that is it it'll make him
complete yes you know that's how he
talks about finding love right it's his
sense of purpose yes and he would never
be late for a date like you were no way
he would be early he's gentlemanly he's
very into
being formal and he wears suits and he's
just such a gentleman um
yes you're right a punctual thanks for
pointing that out
he would have had a lot more success
with
jesse than i did he also has a new
podcast of his own yes called it's a
great podcast mr a plus and it's as
authentic and interesting
as he is as a person and i think one of
the things that we're both drawn to with
michael is that he is just so
honest um
everyone on the show really is there's
something so refreshing about that
especially like you said on reality tv
and we're so used to seeing people
perform maybe i said that uh and you're
agreeing with your own point
that's a good point whoever made that
anyway um you're about to meet him if
you don't know him uh and like christian
said you should check out the show and
check out michael's podcast and here he
is michael himself uh the very charming
the just the sweetest funniest
michael theo
life could be a dream
[Music]
i just finished the second season i
can't wait to talk to you about it um
and about everything in your life but
you must have this experience now with
people where they seem familiar
with you uh strangers what does that
feel like when i'm sure people approach
you on the street now and want to know
you know how you're doing and want to
know details well the thing is um i do
get people coming up to me complimenting
me how much they love the show and how
much they love me and my family etc it's
flattering
it's not annoying okay it's never been
enough there's never been one where you
think okay it's time to time to
move on with our day no because it's not
like it happens all day on a daily basis
yeah were you comfortable being filmed
when they when they were actually
shooting the show did you ever was there
ever a moment where you felt like it was
invasive no i didn't think it felt
invasive it wasn't
i actually enjoyed it oh good so it was
natural you never
you never felt like you were aware of
the cameras what did that feel like to
have cameras follow you around well at
first it seemed um a little bit unusual
but
it didn't take me very long for me
to get used to it i it's funny i
remember when you went on the date with
heather and she she mentioned that she
liked the bachelor
yeah and
you kind of gave a look that suggested
you don't like the bachelor it's because
personally i've never seen it and the
other thing is oh i'm not really a fan
of those shows like that yes no i can
understand i am
it's a guilty pleasure of mine they all
seem to you don't know the show but they
they seem to kind of perform for the
cameras and they seem to have
some type of awareness of the cameras
and what i love one of the things i love
about love on the spectrum is that all
of you seem
very much yourselves you seem very
at ease with with the cameras being
around so that doesn't surprise me to
hear you say that well it's it's not
scripted um we just be ourselves and we
just say whatever's on our mind it shows
i think that's part of the
appeal of the show it feels very natural
which is why i do feel like i know you
and i want to um
i'd also like to ask you to tell your
mother that she is uh
such a charming entertaining person to
watch thanks
i love her
she seems like um you seem the two of
you seem like you have such a fun kind
of cheeky relationship yeah is that safe
to say yeah that's right because you see
the thing is um
my mother seems to be a bit of a
self-proclaimed expert on me
because um
i've been living with her for 27 years
yeah well she is maybe
yeah she um
oh sorry i interrupted it no no no i i'm
just listening to you i was just gonna
say that um
she has a lot of fond and funny memories
of me while i was growing up
yes she does and occasionally she'll
tell them um on the show she look she
like really
relishes talking about those those fun
memories and like she's very
charmed by you and you you guys just
seem like you have such a lovely
relationship
so it's one of my favorite parts of the
show is watching you interact although
well the relationship is not perfect
no well okay let's
let's talk about the dirt let's
let's um what are the imperfections well
well we sometimes get exasperated with
each other uh-huh yeah i can imagine
yeah in what form does that usually take
what's what's a good example of that
michael
well the thing is um there are some
things about me that she um does find a
little bit annoying at times
but if i would in if
if you were to guess what her number one
most annoying thing is what do you think
she'd say
um
that's actually a bit
um
well
like everybody else i also have um
imperfections as well yeah yeah of
course i mean god i'm
i'm loaded with them so i understand
well
sometimes i can be
kind of stubborn uh-huh me too if i have
something i want to do or i feel like
needs to be done
a certain way i i i can't make
adjustments it's hard for me to yeah for
example i i'm looking for this receipt i
can't find it anywhere and it would be
so easy for me to just call up
the hotel and say hey can you send
another one or email them or something
but i i know i have it somewhere and yet
and so i'm i'm driving myself nuts
trying to find this thing when it'd be a
lot easier to call them well
my suggestion would be um to keep
receipts in your in your pocket on your
person at all times
that's a good idea yeah i should do that
i i don't have a wallet either i i'm
annoyed by wallets oh i know mike
michael just gave a very shocked look
you seem surprised by i am because i'm
you see
my father is very old school and he
always taught me taught me that a man
must always have the following on his on
his person at all times his phone his
wallet his keys and his hanky oh i think
wow yeah my dad used to have a hanky i
remember he'd carry he'd i remember that
those are early memories does your dad
still have a hanky that's very
old-fashioned yeah he still uses wow and
does that ever gross you out because to
me it always seemed a little gross to be
blowing your nose into a cloth and then
keeping it well the thing is um
it may seem gross to others but to me it
just feels normal because if you need to
sneeze or blow your nose just use a
hanky but
if you're coughing up green yuki
a mu green yuki substance that's right
you can't keep that no that's right
that's when you use a tissue and you
have to wash them right it's also
environmentally friendly to use a hanky
yeah um hankies do require washing gear
all right well you're selling me on the
hanky a little bit it's um
is your dad somebody because i know you
love formality um
did your dad was was he somebody that
got you interested in that is that where
that interest started as a child
actually he didn't he only got me into
um
wearing suits and ties okay where did
your other interest in formality come
from
well my dad has always taught me
old school values
things the old-fashioned way that makes
sense you you seem
you you seem like such a gentleman on
the show um i was listening to your
podcast which is so good it's called mr
a plus
i really loved it with with uh you had
your friend brianna on the show yeah she
was asking you about
how did you you met at university no not
university um i never went to university
oh okay i actually met 10 years ago in
2011 in our
senior year of high school um i
absolutely adore her and i get it she's
like probably my closest female friend
and yeah she's opened my eyes to a lot
of things and she accomplished something
that i previously thought that i'd never
be able to do which is which is what
live overseas oh
oh so where did she live that inspired
you well she lived she's lived in france
peru and germany oh wow okay well i know
that you spent some time in germany is
that what inspired you to go there
actually um
she invited me to stay with her for two
weeks
oh cool
oh wow what was that like it was very
enjoyable
yeah
just a whole different culture huh what
was it about what what struck you the as
being the most different and the most
exciting about germany well my dad told
me once that
the people of germany seem to be a very
a quite serious kind of people and that
appealed to me because i'm actually
quite a serious person myself and yes so
is my dad for that matter your parents
are a really good balance i noticed
because your dad you're right yeah
definitely does seem more serious but
your mom is so playful yeah that's
interesting michael that you say that
brianna opened your eyes because she she
said something about you on your show
that that i really related to which is
that um
essentially that that you opened her
eyes and and you she she really loves
the way you see the world and and i
found myself really identifying with
that and agreeing with her and i think
that's
why i find you so appealing like you
you you have such a unique such a
different approach to um
to life and to human interaction i and i
love how honest you are you you're such
an honest person yeah i'm brutally
honest
you you are but you know what it's it's
refreshing because i think we live in a
day and age where
that that's rare um
do you ever
get in trouble for your honesty are you
do you ever find that you are
too honest with people and and does that
ever lead to anything um
problematic no good but if i'm too
brutally honest it could come across as
being offensive to some people yes but
it's not intended that way no i think
it's that's clear i don't your
intentions seem very
good you seem like you have really good
intention like even when the way you
i guess broke up with heather um that
phone call well technically we we didn't
break up because we were never together
um right that's true we just went on
dates but the thing is she had a lot of
commitments at the time and a
relationship just would have been
a hindrance yes that's true and she she
seemed like when you called her she
seemed like she was
very busy distracted yeah you strike me
as somebody who doesn't like
disappointing people
yeah but i also find it disappointing
how a lot of people on social media say
that she ghosted me but she didn't well
that must be frustrating because
maybe it seemed like that to people
because they don't show obviously they
can only show a little bit of
your the life that that they filmed yeah
so
maybe through editing it seemed
different than yeah
because they didn't exactly film the
entire um
situation you talk a lot i mean of
course the show is your journey finding
love and um
you you talk a lot about the importance
of love
can you tell people why you
want to find that love that ultimate
love
it's because
being single your whole life seems like
it's unfulfilling and kind of uh
boring some people are uncomfortable
being single their heart their whole
lives but i'm not because
when you're married to a woman
it kind of makes you a king
a king
a lot of people these days see marriage
as just a piece of paper that's called a
marriage certificate but right it's the
principle of marriage the principle is
marriage is the spiritual and emotional
bond between two souls agreeing to
spending and sharing their lives
together the relationship that you want
you want to find somebody who
that you can do that with that you can
spend
a life with exactly
so but you know
i i've heard you say versions of that on
the show and every time it strikes me
that you seem already so
fulfilled you say
that without that it's life is
unfulfilling and boring but you don't
seem like you live a boring life at all
you seem
like the opposite oh
well that's a little bit surprising
because i don't feel that way sometimes
oh really
well i don't i mean i'm sure not all the
time but but you um you seem
do you so you don't feel right now that
you are fulfilled i sometimes i don't
because the thing is yeah
i've done very little travel throughout
my life and i've
i've never had a girlfriend and i still
live with my parents embarrassingly
that's not embarrassing i mean you're
also quite young i mean i know when you
talk about wanting to find a partner you
you talk about it like
you're over the hill or something you're
past your prime but you're so young to
me but i'm only 27. i know
i know i know so i guess what i'm saying
is that maybe brianna says the same
thing to you is that you have a lot of
time yeah you don't feel that way i
never really
felt for any kind of um time running out
oh that's good okay i never felt so you
know
oh that's good yeah nor should you and
by the way i was also thinking this that
to travel because i know you love you
talk about loving travel traveling it
might even be easier to travel
while you're
single you know before you're in a
serious relationship i don't know i
think so
what are some of the places besides i
know you've been to germany and uh and
hawaii i think yeah that's right and
what are some of some of the other
places you'd love to go to the us
uh-huh oh where where in the u.s do you
have a specific place in mind not
exactly but um
maybe somewhere that's beautiful and
possibly a good opportunity to find
acting work because that's what i'm
pursuing
oh that's right okay
i did hear that on your podcast as well
and
what type of acting would you see
yourself doing would you like to do
voice acting and television acting oh
yeah you you have such a great voice you
do such great characters will you do
some who are your who are your favorites
to do one of them is scar from the lion
king please sure can i talk to scar i'd
like to ask scar um
scar uh
what places do you want to go visit
well um other places that i'd love to
visit would be um quite possibly great
britain
um
lions in great britain um italy spain um
also maybe portugal
oh man that's great michael that's
really good and
also um
canada as well canada you don't hear
that too often on a wish list but i love
canada also michael that's really good
it sounds so much like him
who played that who who did that in the
original jeremy ions oh that's right
jeremy irons he's he's english himself
that's right and jeremy irons are very
proper right and and i heard you do um
you do a great scooby
but obviously i can't can't do this as
well as don messick did r.i.p oh yeah
don music and didn't uh casey case oh
casey kasem did shaggy then
oh okay i didn't know don messick passed
away yeah he died in 1997. oh okay
wherever
i'll explain um back in 1996 he had his
first stroke which ended his which
forced him into retirement from voice
acting and then the following year 1997
um three months after madame black was
released
he um
passed away from his second stroke at
the age of 71. wow that's young to die
from a stroke losing him along with mel
blanc and doc and doris butler left a
large void in the voice acting world oh
yeah what you know who now i know mel
blank who's dos butler doris buffer was
also another voice actor at
hanna-barbera he did
um cogswell and
elroy jetson from the jetsons oh yeah
yeah yeah
you know who i always loved who was the
guy who was him she did the droopy dog
going down that guy you remember him was
that dawn messick uh it might have been
don messick i gotta look that up i'll
look it up later what what
did
drew droopy dog he was in um i don't
remember
i was droopy dogging i just always loved
that voice and there was a great disney
short um
the ranger brownstone do you ever see
that one with uh haven't oh god he
talked like this he was about a bunch of
bears at yellowstone national park uh j
look at if you look it up i'm sure it's
on youtube i i bet you get a kick out of
it i haven't really seen a lot of hannah
barbara's work
um well i think it's disney yeah
because you see the thing is um
i'm more mostly into television shows
okay
that makes sense well you know we had
eric bowser who's a great a new voice
actor i bet eric um i should connect you
guys because eric is he does the voice
of bugs bugs bunny and and yeah a ton of
porky pig and a ton of the looney tunes
voices yeah and jeffy redmond as well
jeff bergman uh he might have some good
advice though for you so how
are you planning on pursuing that
michael well i do have an agent
oh good here in new south wales oh great
um and there's some other things going
on in the works but i don't really know
much information about them at the
moment
but i'm definitely pursuing acting for a
career good for you because that's great
and my passion is what i really want to
do
yeah you know i know you know a lot
about movies and stuff so what are some
of the movies that really inspired you
to want to be an actor it wasn't exactly
films themselves that inspired me it was
just the whole concept of it you know
actors performing at you know in front
of an audience being entertained by them
yeah and the applause that come that
comes with it is part of it to playing
different characters and and then escape
into different characters yeah
definitely
i want to be a versatile performer yeah
although my much preferred um favorite
genre is comedy okay yeah well what kind
of comedies um like physical comedy or
are you like a stand-up comedy not so
much stand up because i don't know any
jokes but i try try to tell a joke it it
doesn't come off as funny because it's
just me trying too hard
right but you are
funny just not just yourself um and of
course not to
number three compliment to your mom but
you have very funny people around you
yeah uh which which is which is nice um
yeah what are some of the movies that
that you love some of the comedies that
you love well there's sonic the hedgehog
with jim carrey oh
oh yeah right i gotta see that one yeah
i'm looking forward to seeing the sequel
next year oh that's right yeah there's
also um several disney films as well
uh-huh yeah cause i'm quiet to animation
oh that's what it sounds like yes um so
voice acting is what you'd like to focus
on as well yes yeah yeah well god
michael i
i'm really rooting for you i i think you
and you have a great voice i love when
you were on the date you did those
impressions um thanks justin you did a
couple of they really seemed charmed by
you um
and also i love that you don't let
your
autism get in the way of any of that
that you don't let it get in the way of
uh
pursuing those things um
was that is it would you say that that
was your parents doing that they um
that the way they handled that no i
wouldn't say that um i think it was
something that i was born with and yeah
uh technically i it's not really autism
that i have it's what i have is called
asperger's exam oh right a modern form
of autism okay so
explain to people the difference between
the two um
what i have is high functioning
asperger's that means
i guess you can say that i'm almost
considered a normal person you know a
neurotypical and people with with autism
it could be a bit stronger for some
people
but others not so much yes that's right
that's that was another thing i found
fascinating about the show is that
i mean they say it's a spectrum there
really is like a very wide
range of people did you um do you watch
the show michael after it airs i did
watch it when when the episode's dead
yeah and what was that like the first
time like the first season
the first experience of doing that well
when i
watched the first season when the
episode aired i was somewhat proud but
also um kind of embarrassed because it
felt a little bit weird watching
yourself on screen huh yeah what what's
what stood out what was the weirdest
part um just some of the things i said
because i did cringe a fair bit you mean
you cringed on the show no i cringed
while i was watching it god if some of
my dates had been filmed oof
i'd i'd want to i'd be i'd want to
cringe through
[Music]
not to brag but i was getting a massage
whoa
professional buy a professional and i
was in the waiting room i had some time
to kill so
lo and behold pulled out my phone and i
uh started playing some best fiends for
about 10 minutes it's a puzzle game and
you love puzzles uh that anyone can
download and play there's not any rules
about who can do it in your phone and
it's free you download it and it's got
tons of fun puzzles and there's fun
characters that you collect people like
collecting you can play for hours on end
or like me yesterday i only had a couple
minutes but even for a couple minutes
it's a perfect game for a couple minutes
even yeah it's a nice distraction you
know if you're at like an airport or i
always get a little yeah i want to like
hone in on something but it's a nice
combination of
a little mindless but also a little
mindful because it requires brain work
it's got thousands of levels and
challenges so it's you never get tired
of playing and not to brag i'm on level
57 now i believe but are there 58 levels
there's like thousands of likes oh so
i'm not a brag no it's not but it makes
me feel good knowing how many more are
ahead of me should i choose to play more
yeah and you can play with which i will
you can play with best friends you can
play best fiends with best friends or
best enemies yeah and it's it's free to
download and play yeah anyway
download best fiends free today on the
app store or google play that's friends
without the r
best fiends
i recently purchased a home i got very
lucky in many respects uh one of which
was my realtor is our older brother's
father-in-law had i known
about how to buy a home podcast that
would have also filled in a lot of money
yeah posted by a guy named david sidone
he's an industry expert with years of
experience who cares who actually cares
about first time home buyers his how to
buy a home podcast can help you whether
you've already started looking for home
or if you've been too overwhelmed to
even think about starting sounds like
something i would do yeah he answers
questions like when is the best time to
start how do i even start will a
mortgage be more than my current monthly
rent by the way probably not
do i need an 800 credit score no no
that's weird i can answer that now you
can uh because people are buying homes
with credit scores in the 600s so these
are things that like obviously yeah i
would never have known and if you're
like us or even if you're more
knowledgeable than us you still i mean i
think anyone who's thinking about buying
a home uh could could glean something
from this podcast just check out the
reviews here's a couple samples david
really goes above and beyond in helping
people out in this super confusing real
estate landscape he is very upbeat and
professional and tells you exactly what
you need to know while motivating you
and here's another and he they're right
she's right that's right here's another
review from someone uh whose name i
don't know but i imagine they sound like
this i feel like i'm stealing when i
listen to his this podcast it feels like
this information shouldn't be free but
i'm so thankful it is
seriously if you're thinking about
buying a home next month next year or in
five years
do yourself a favor check out the how to
buy a home podcast today find how to buy
a home wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
have you met actors since the show
actors that you know have you met
anybody since the show
only through
the podcast oh yes that's right who have
you had on well the only home actor that
i've actually had so far is shane
jacobson shane jacobson he's um an
australian actor okay cool
michael you you had mentioned don
messick uh yeah you had mentioned men in
black came out around the time of his
death well actually he died three months
after it came out oh after so was he in
men this is a dumb question
forgive me but was he in men in black no
he wasn't oh okay you're just using that
as a point of reference yeah at this
time because they both happened in the
same year i was only three years old at
the time okay wow that's right yeah well
i'm see i'm older i'm so to me
when men in black came out that was a
great time for movies that's when i was
re i
like you are now i was
falling in love with the idea of being
an actor and um
those were some of my favorite movies
that came out during that time but there
is a certain actor for men in black that
i really admire a lot oh who's that
tommy lee jones oh yes well you know he
is supposed to be very serious and um
a very intense
actor yeah to work with
very bright you know he was um he was
roommates actually with al gore
at harvard
yeah yeah i read about that oh okay you
already knew that well thanks for acting
surprised well it's because i'm i've
researched about celebrities on imdb for
years oh okay oh you would have loved
this guy i had the occasion to sit uh at
a dinner with the guy who started imdb
do you know anything about him no oh you
you would really love him because he is
um
and i know i know you he he loves
collecting things he loved collecting
all this information and that's kind of
how imdb started was just his interest
in who was in this and who was in that
and um yeah i remember when i was a kid
i always loved that i had a book
about movies leonard malton's
movie book and i love just kind of
knowing who was in what and when what
years things came out yeah that was
always really interesting
yeah
and i also happen to know the eu are
born
oh do you
1978 i believe yes it's true michael in
fact
i have a strange write-up on imdb i
don't know who wrote it
but it says something like i have um i
forget it used to say i i had thick
eyebrows i had heavy eyebrows um and
isn't that when you trademarks is it
well
maybe i i never thought of it that way
and not to mention boyish looks boyish
yes yeah well boyish is nice when you're
younger but
boyish gets a little strange as you age
i suppose that's what i'm going through
yeah yeah so you have to me you have a a
very
rugged like man you say solid build yeah
and and a more and like a mature face
and and i was always jealous of people
who could
shake i mean for example i bet you could
grow a full beard i could but the thing
is i'm not kane oh really you've never
done it nah plus but when i've stopped
it it gets itchy see i don't know
because i can't do this but don't they
say that it's only a couple days with
that you have to brave the stubble and
then and then you have a nice thick
lustrous
beard
um i'm not sure i've never done it well
aren't you curious to try it not really
no okay
okay
um that reminds me of one of the
embarrassing stories your mom told on
the show
was when you tried to shave your chest
yeah
yeah that was just some how oh sorry you
you asked the question oh oh oh well i
was gonna say i was gonna i guess my
question is um what was that experience
like i did not even enjoy it that was
just a box that was just a botched
attempt to um
see what i would look like if i was
but i did not like i did not like the
look of myself one bit
well did it look it probably looked so
different it probably looked
yeah and you have to how much did you
have to shave do you have to you have to
shave the whole thing i guess yeah
and did your mom
how quickly does she start laughing when
you show her
your attempt she laughed almost
instantly
okay
so
so
do you i mean
it's so nice it's i love that you can
tease you can choke with each other
does does she ever go too far does she
ever like
laugh when when you're still feeling
like kind of hurt by something no she
doesn't do that
no she seems like a really sweet person
yes
but then again she does also sometimes
remind me of
gloria pritchett or modern family oh
which ones which who plays that
character sophia agara oh okay sophia
vergara yeah she does in what way does
she remind you it's because they both
have latin genes um
they're both very loud when they talk um
loving supportive mothers
and oh yeah they're very passionate yes
oh that's good those are nice things to
say when have you told her that she
reminds you of that character yes she
does
okay and what did she
and what did she how did she react she
takes it with a pinch of salt
also true
that the actress melissa fumero who's
who does an amazing job in brooklyn 99
um
she also has a few things in common with
my mother oh oh interesting yeah i know
who you're talking about she also of
latin descent right yeah she's she has a
cuban background okay
the three things that that melissa
vamera has in common with my mother is
that they both have latin genes they
both have olive skin and they both have
very expressive faces your mom does have
an expressive face melissa fumero is
somebody i would love to interview on my
podcast oh well let's put the word out
how do you reach out to somebody like
that i actually have a producer who and
a crew is able to contact people to get
them on board oh that's great and and i
know that some people reach out to you
you had told brianna on your show that
uh some friends some people reached out
to you
uh because they saw you on the show yeah
and that you're now friends with yeah
what is that like how does that happen
do they do it through
social media yeah social media it also
depends on where where they're based
oh oh of course yeah i mean they'd have
to be close to you right now yeah
because the thing is i'm based in new
south wales which is a state of
australia
so what what describe to people what
that is like is it um is it a very
remote place it's not very remote no um
where i come from is
a coastal town on a in a region called
the illawarra illawarra
yeah huh that's a river no it's not a
river um it's a coastal region oh okay
so it's right on the water oh beautiful
must be beautiful yeah um it's more
specifically the south coast of new
south wales south of sydney oh okay okay
so okay i see you're on the east it's
the eastern side yeah that's right oh
okay so i've been to sydney michael and
i've been to melbourne yeah um and those
are those the only two places i remember
being in bairam babe uh
is that a place yeah byron bay that's um
close to the border of um queensland i
didn't get to stay as long as i i wish
but i can't wait to i can't wait to go
back
do you recommend that i go
to visit new south wales yeah i would
recommend it what type of things should
i do if i go there well
you could check out wollongong that's
the town i live in okay great how do you
say it wollongong wollongong is that an
aboriginal name
i not sure huh wollongong okay do you
know how to spell it i just i just did
it phonetically so i spelt it
w-o-l-o-n-g-o-n-g
yeah but it's actually spelt
double l o n o g o n g oh i was close
yeah you were
so that was nail off yeah i don't often
get close to things yes i'm usually way
off
and
i'm also this may come as a little bit
of a surprise to you but i'm actually
quite a fan of new girl oh that's great
oh fun that's a good show i like that
show and plus you are cool on that show
yes i i was lucky enough to be on
some episodes i i actually michael um
got that job before it was ever on the
air so
i i didn't know what the show you know
how it would look how it would all come
together i i did the show because um i
really liked uh
two of the zoe deschanel and um jake
johnson are
two of my favorites and um and and and i
now love all of them
and
max uh greenfield there's it was such a
great group to be but you know i i i
always wanted to do more stuff with the
guys you know my my stuff was all with
um and i like zoey a lot but i love
doing stuff with those guys they're so
funny but i also gotta ask you what's
what's zoey like as a person
oh she is very well she's very funny
she's very quick-witted
yeah um you look very excited to hear
this uh she is a great musician
really one have you heard her music i
don't think i have
oh okay well she
check it out michael she's in a group
called she and him
with with another really great musician
named m ward um so it's if you just look
up she and him wait a second doesn't she
play the ukulele yeah she plays the
ukulele she has a beautiful singing
voice really incredible singing voice
and um
she is uh i it was just such a fun group
of people to to
be around it was such a wonderful job i
loved that i loved it yeah we got to
make up some dialogue you know we got to
improvise which i like doing
um i yeah although i will admit people
could should appreciate the show a bit
more yeah what do you mean by that i've
heard that it's underrated oh
what system what rating system i don't i
don't know about ranks but i think it's
like maybe by the audience maybe because
they don't really pay much attention to
it oh maybe well that's another thing
you kind of learn as an actor is to you
learn to not really pay so much
attention to that stuff to who if people
like it or they don't like it obviously
you hope they like it yeah which is and
it's always nice to hear i bet you feel
that way when people come up to you
about love on the spectrum and say how
much they like yeah the show it must
feel
you you understand it feels it feels
good it's definitely flattering yes
it is yeah i love that you're meeting
new friends because of the show yeah
yeah did um are you still in touch with
those people who uh
none of them accept one oh oh who's that
my name's rosie oh how nice okay and she
lives near you oh she actually lives in
the blue mountains oh okay so oh that's
where cassandra lives right on the show
yeah cassandra for those of you who
don't know cassandra's another character
on another person should say character
real people on the show did you get to
do you get to meet your fellow casters
only did at um at photo shoots oh okay
because you see what was that ex yeah oh
sorry i interrupted again no no i did it
again um because you see um a lot of the
other participants they live um more in
the sydney suburbs okay so you have you
kept in touch with any of them did you
get to be friends with anybody not on
the show not really no yeah and the
other thing is that remember i said that
um
i mentioned my podcast a couple of times
yeah mr a plus yeah it has a strict no
covertal policy oh that's right i
yeah you say that in the beginning i
like that i like uh why the no kovid
because the media has done a lot of
damage to the world they've reported
about it every day for two years
straight yes and it's caused a lot of
people a lot of fear and it's and worry
it's done that to me already the damage
is already done
and i know and not to mention the fact
that our lives are continuously being
disrupted because of all this i know it
is such a bummer i know it's true
my mother she watches the news all day
that's all she does and all they do is
talk about covet and so she's i mean she
was always a pretty
you know anxious person but she's now
even more so i mean she is
worried constantly but that that's a big
concern will you please tell her name is
wendy will you please tell wendy
say wendy you gotta stop watching and
tell me why
wendy if you're hearing this
i need to give you some advice stop
watching the news it's all it's doing is
causing you a lot of
mental damage as destroying your
emotions
just don't watch the news just
watch something more light-hearted
something that brings love and light
into people's lives or even yes read
read a book or um go for walks go to
garden park or something anything that
anything that's not related to the virus
ah okay well she
she doesn't listen to me she'll
hopefully listen to you thank you for
doing that i like that you said
i like that you said to read or watch
something that brings love and light
into the world because that's what you
say on your show yeah yeah i love that
idea michael that um i i want to expose
myself to more of that i think everyone
should such a nice um it's such a nice
reminder in your show it's because um
there's too much darkness and animosity
in this world
yes i know i agree another problem is
kind people are very scarce these days
yeah why do you think that is that kind
people are scarce because uh too many
people are just very selfish
they would only give people the time of
day if they either need a favor or
believe they will gain something from it
yeah there's not a lot of selfless
actions i know um
yeah what i i like on the show that they
they have each person describe things
that they like that they'd like and
things that they dislike yeah um will
you remind people remind me too um what
what are your what were your likes and
dislikes
i'm not really a fan of um
of traffic jams i also don't yes i don't
like cold weather or hot weather
and uh-huh i also can't stand um loud
noises as well
aha yeah like like car horns and stuff
huh and also loud music as well okay
well
michael i know i know you're thinking
about coming to the united states if you
do come here maybe avoid new york city
maybe avoid new york what about l.a um
there are parts of la that are really
peaceful and and lovely and a lot of i
know you like nature
there's a lot of nature there that can
be really beautiful
yeah la is nice and like a lot of actors
you might you maybe you'll you go on one
of those sightseeing tours you might see
an actor yeah
although i have to admit that um if i
ever encountered an actor or actress in
america
i wouldn't go up to them and
ask them for an autograph or a selfie i
would only accept it only if they
offered it that is a really good
way to be that is a really good rule
because of course how would they offer
it if you didn't go up to them i suppose
um i would just i'm simply
do what we're doing just have a normal
civilized conversation there are no they
are normal people like the rest of us
yeah exactly i i think that's a really
good approach i think that that will
pay off i i find that the way you
described approaching somebody is a lot
more rare now it's rare to have somebody
respectfully come up and
you know just say they enjoy something
or you were so respectful you were so
nice about new girl like if you came up
to me in the world and said hey uh you
know i enjoy the show new girl it'd be
so nice to hear
um but people don't always do that they
like to get photos and sneak pictures
and stuff um because you see when it
comes to interacting with a celebrity
what i really really want to do with
celebrities is mostly um have a meal
with them you know lunch or dinner you
know
casually who would be your number one
pick if you could pick any celebrity to
do that with any at all yeah yeah
obviously alive yes but there's a whole
there's a whole list of people that i'd
love to do it with if i at a dinner you
get to have a dinner with five other
people okay there's there would be
rossum and pike and she's my favorite
she's my favorite british actress
melissa romero uh-huh because she's
quite funny as well
oh okay um
from brooklyn nine-nine that you
mentioned earlier
yeah mark evan jackson i admire him a
lot
he's an australian no he's not he's
american he's that he's okay he's a
comedian but he has um a very
distinctive deadpan delivery and his
characters are very strict and
authoritative and he's something i would
love to have on my podcast i would even
love to work with him
okay great oh man and two more
um yeah but these two are people that
you had on your podcast
oh okay who are they maybe i can
hook it up
chris and belle she's undying okay
yeah she's the same she has the same
heart as my mother oh that's the same
heart i said height height yeah oh yes
she does
she does um
you know you know what i i am going to
i'm gonna text her right now and uh
listen and and let her know because you
know what i have a feeling she watches
the show because with chris and bill i
love her she's so funny no matter what
she does okay all right wait i'm gonna
unplug my earphones so you can deliver
her a message okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
first say hi to her okay
denny denny i have a little bit of a
surprise here i have my friend michael
theo
who is from the show love on the
spectrum and he wants to say something
to you now who is it
okay go ahead michael who is it on the
phone oh it's crystal okay i'm leaving
her a mess we're leaving our message
okay all right so you go okay i gotta
say
grizz and bill i think you are
absolutely funny and hilarious and
the fact that you're
and your height also kind of helps
because um
you are absolutely brilliant on the good
place it's actually one of my favorite
shows
i just can't really describe
what an absolute pleasure it is to even
to even speak with you or even interview
you or let alone work with you
um
i think you're an absolute delight uh
a very rare light in this world
just keep yes perfect okay perfect
michael that's great um so denny you
heard it uh and michael's got a show
um called mr a plus if you ever want to
be on it let me know and i'll connect
you with michael okay all right sorry
okay i'm gonna send that to her i have a
feeling that kristen likes the show
that your show and that would be great
if that worked out okay i'll let you
know nice lovely um thank you justin
also and finally the fifth person
she's also been on your podcast okay
and she was also on the good place well
give me a hint i want to guess i want to
guess this could be a fun game um oh she
was also in the good place okay i i
should have waited it's jim
darcy cardin no chamilla
yes i love her
yes she has a wonderful accent you're
right for me it's a yes kind of a
turn-on
yes yeah a turn on yeah well
probably shouldn't say that to her but
um no maybe there's a way to say that
where it's respectful yeah well how
would you how would you say that in a
respectful way what i mean is um
british accents are my favorite and
i just find them very beautiful that's
what i meant
because because they because they're
sophisticated and they also
have a hint of culture about him yes uh
and hers has a lot of more than a house
oh just the way she dresses on
on the good place it is exceptionally
beautiful yes yeah she is really like
yeah really stunning and she's a very
funny person to me she's like she's
almost like a goddess oh yeah she's
great well i'll leave her a message too
and see if she'd want to do i bet i bet
you she would i bet you should be into
your show i would actually would love
her to be on my podcast
[Music]
[Music]
we're running out of time but i have a i
have a lightning round yeah
uh uh a quick round of um just quick
questions if you don't mind cool go for
it okay okay great um number one what is
your favorite emoji
i don't really have one okay uh do you
is there one that you use
more often than others probably i'm one
of those smiling ones okay
yeah like the big smile yeah yeah
yeah yeah i like that one um who was
your first celebrity crush um probably
miranda cosgrove
miranda cosgrove how do i know that name
she was on icarly oh okay on
nickelodeon
yeah and what is your favorite ice cream
flavor anything that's fruit flavored oh
really like um we have a thing here
where i live called black raspberry ice
cream oh have you ever heard of black
raspberry i haven't ugh it is so good it
is um
it's creamy but also fruity because you
see i'm more into gelato oh gelato i
like how you pronounce it it's um
vanessa's the italian way yes yeah
that's my dad does that too because my
dad loves italy and so whenever we go to
a restaurant he'll say you know i want
the fettuccine
right
because you see i'm a quarter italian oh
okay oh yeah theo would that be on your
dad's side by that side yes and and so
so what's your favorite gelato flavor
like uh
fruity what's your favorite fruit it
would be um something citrus or
watermelon oh yum yeah do you ever watch
the show curb your enthusiasm i don't
think i have oh oh okay it's it's a fun
show here you might like but there was
an episode about watermelon that was
very funny uh what is your what is your
favorite holiday new year's eve michael
what is a movie like an acclaimed i know
you you've seen a lot of movies but
what's one movie that
you're maybe a little embarrassed to
admit you haven't seen that everybody
always says
they can't believe you haven't seen
such and such
it would probably be
there's a whole list of films that i
haven't seen yeah what's what's on the
top of your list um it's a bit hard to
say
okay well
um well maybe it'll come to you but
because there's so many you're saying
yeah there's there's thousands of films
in the world yeah that is true that's
true
um what is a game show pastor present
that you'd want to be a contestant on
any show that's hosted by
mayan bialik oh yeah oh jeopardy yeah
she hosts she hosts jeopardy yeah in
fact i actually admire her as well
because um
because of her brilliant mind
she does have a yes she was
a scientist a neuro the biggest
neurology right
yeah that's right yep oh yeah oh okay
yeah who um do you have she's your
favorite character yeah she's one of
them and there's only one more who's
that take a guess
um it's gotta be uh
it's gotta be jim parsons character
sheldon i actually would like to
interview him as well
oh okay well maybe you're i don't know
jim i wish i did i know johnny galecki a
little i could reach out to him and if
if if jim is actually watching this i
think he should know that i happen to
have this oh michael is holding up a
pride flag as proof that i support that
community yeah well jim if you're
listening to this
michael does in fact have a pride flag
and very much supports your community
because because literally anybody could
say that they support that community but
the secret question is do you
and what better way to to prove it than
by having one of these
that's true well now i feel like i'm not
really an ally because i don't think
that i have a
a little mini pride flag well the choice
is it's optional you make me think i
should have one uh you know what i do
have is a little mini
uh flag from iceland i was recently in
iceland oh
and uh so i guess i support that the
icelandic how is that um
oh michael it is i you should put that
on your list i know spain and portugal
are on your list and they're on mine too
because i'd like to go to those places
but
you should put iceland on your list
because it is unlike anything i've ever
seen i i
just
beautiful natural
spectacles it's like another world is it
does it get very cold there well yeah it
does yes
yeah well like i tried to sell you and
then i lost you well um i guess i could
there's an iceland at some point go in
the go when it's warm go in the
summertime yeah
but the question is when i'm gonna be at
summer um that's a good question i think
well it's in the northern hemisphere so
i know you for you guys it's reversed
right yeah like like right now are you
in your summer yeah we're in summer oh
okay yeah see see right where i am in i
mean connecticut it's
called it's gonna snow soon it's really
cold yikes so you probably wouldn't like
that i know you don't like the cold and
the hot but it must it must get really
hot in new south wales at times it does
um
two years ago we went through a period
called the black summer which which had
a lot of bush fires
oh yes oh god that was devastating yeah
yeah that was bad but where i lived um
where i live um we were we were safe
from it because we're not near any bush
land we're in suburbia
oh okay all right and and you're near
the water like you said that must be
that must keep it a little bit more well
we're on the coast yeah do you drink
coffee or tea michael and if so how do
you take um i sometimes drink tea i only
drink mochas
and
what is that maca is a type of coffee
and you put milk do you drink milk with
it yeah milk yes
and maybe like two sugars at least okay
a little bit sweet um if you could learn
another language what would that be
probably either spanish or italian and i
also do do drink tea
fruit flavored tea okay blueberry
blackcurrant flavored teas
and also mango and strawberry flavored
teas those that sounds delicious we used
to have a question what is your favorite
fruit and i feel like i have to bring
that back for you because you seem like
you like
fruit flavored things what so if you had
an actual piece of fruit what would your
choice be green apple green apple really
because you see i've been eating them
every day for several years oh really
great yeah do you in australia do you
call it a granny smith yeah okay huh
uh that's interesting because it's so
tart
yeah yeah you like the wow okay green
apple do you eat it on its own or do you
put any peanut butter on a side okay
every day for years
yep wow my current job in my previous
job and even my years of school okay
well what is what is your current job i
work at a kitchen manufacturer but um
i'm pursuing acting oh that's career
because it's what i really want to do
that's right so are the
are the people at your current job are
they understanding of that are they like
flexible with with that um
they seem to be at the moment but um
but when my acting career takes off i'm
gonna have to yeah well yeah yeah you
would
yeah you would have to i won't have a
choice that's true what is your favorite
cereal
michael
i actually don't eat cereal oh really
never i did when i was younger but yeah
i
somehow stopped eating yeah i did too i
guess what so what's a typical breakfast
for you um i would have apple and yogurt
or eggs with toast okay or even um
[Music]
or even
corn thins with hummus and salsa so you
don't like vegemite i actually do use it
oh you do toast oh okay would that be
more of a breakfast item in australia i
think so but you can also use it on
sandwiches as well that's right yeah i
just remember going there and
god they they offer i was offered it all
the time people loved it
um very healthy right um i suppose it
would be but it does contain a fair bit
of salt oh oh oh okay
if you had to choose a different first
name
other than michael obviously what would
it be maybe uh
edward
edward that's a good name a strong kind
of regal name
yeah yeah i like that um edward theo if
you had a michael if you had a sandwich
named after you the michael theo
sandwich what what would be on it what
would you put on it that's a bit hard to
decide because i never really put any
thought into that oh you know so you're
not a big sandwich guy not exactly oh
okay because
i've had i've had them for years
yeah and is there a fave do you have a
favorite of the sandwiches you've had um
well there is one
the three things i promised used to put
on sandwiches all the time um
but my parent my family doesn't really
like it that much it's got salami egg
and cheese whoa
oh that's not
that's kind of interesting well i love
like a bacon egg and cheese or a ham i
get vegan cheese so why not
huh i never thought to put salami with
eggs why not it's very italian
yeah it is
because you see my family i get deli
meats all all the time oh including
salami wow you know what michael i'm
gonna try that i'm gonna and i'm gonna
call it the michael theo when i do it if
someone says nice well i'm eating it if
somebody says what are you eating i'm
gonna say i'm eating a michael theo
um what is your favorite tom hanks movie
probably the toy story franchise oh yeah
man i i don't know about you i find
myself just weeping when i watch those
movies i'm a mess
in fact woody kind of reminds me of my
dad oh really oh yes very sturdy very
kind of well the thing i know something
about about woody yeah what's that
he constantly makes everything his
problem he has the personality of a
father yes that's true
and he's always worrying about something
yeah well he's also protective
um which is he has really good quality
yeah yeah yeah do you hope to be a
father one day yourself a couple years
ago i wasn't really so keen on being a
parent but
recently i found myself kind of warming
up to the idea
although if i was given a choice i would
very much prefer to have a daughter
really why is that
because i've always been more drawn to
having
having a girl because yeah i'm back i've
always been more drawn to women yeah
your mom had the experience of raising
both i wonder what she would say well um
my mother was pretty much the main
disciplinarian but she but my dad also
contributed to raising ex raising us as
well yeah yeah no i that's true you well
you should ask them both i guess um
what uh what when would she have to
discipline you the most like what what
what did that what form did that usually
take
maybe when i was being difficult yeah
yeah
i know
my mother had the most difficult the
most challenges raising my brother oh
really because he was the the
least well behaved and he was kind of
also the most rebellious uh i see yeah i
i guess i was too and you know i look
back at some of the stuff i put my
parents through and i really regret it
you know i really wish i'd i wish i'd
done more chores i wish i had helped out
with dinner more
uh oh michael do you like to cook i've
actually started to learn how to cook
recently um i
already know how to make salads and um
eggs and
two twice i've now learned how to cook a
steak oh good oh that's you know i
always thought of cooking steak as being
really easy you know but it's actually
to do it right to do it properly um god
is it hard
sorry let me just put that away oh
that's all right sorry no no don't worry
about it somebody from canada oh do you
need to take it no no no it can wait
wait oh okay michael is it somebody you
know from canada well it's i do know her
but i've never really met her before oh
is this a new prospective partner for me
hopefully oh oh okay that's great
so you met her on
online yeah um
instagram mostly instagram okay because
a friend of hers
um set up this fan page for
for fans of love on the spectrum on
instagram huh they may be the face of it
oh well i can see that and
this person who set it up um introduced
me to this friend of hers named skyla oh
that's a nice name skyler it always
makes me think of goodwill hunting oh
i haven't seen that oh you would like
that it's oh it's a really great movie
matt damon is so good and minnie drive
robin williams oh man he was r.i.p yeah
he was one of the greats yeah he's he
seemed like he seemed like a very great
guy ah just always just
love
laughing and making people laugh and
you know i mentioned his unique voice
ability oh yes well you know what's
funny michael he was i remember being
i remember he would do that for the crew
the whole crew in between takes he would
do his he would do popeye he would do
mrs doubtfire he would do all his like
classic characters and um
i i remember thinking how different they
all sounded you know so you would
definitely appreciate that because yeah
that's what you do with the voices but
it's um yeah man was he special
yeah
i can't believe it i'm losing to a rug
yeah oh that's good that's from aladdin
all right sparky here's the deal
if you want to caught the little lady
gonna be a straight shooter too you got
it
that's good that's really good you know
what's funny when you did that
impression you kind of
looked like him a little bit well i have
to yeah yeah yeah how do you do that do
you imagine those characters in your
head when you do it do you yeah yeah and
plus i have animation in my face as well
yeah yeah you do have a very animated
face it's great like your mom
yeah she does she's quite animated
herself that's why she just articulates
a lot yes oh yes she does well that's
also very talent i do i do it myself
it is italian yeah
and um have you found it easier to date
after the show or is it there's is there
no real difference um
it's kind of made it a bit easier i've
now put myself out out there yeah and
now a lot of people in north america
absolutely love me for some reason yeah
well why do you think that is maybe it's
because um it's maybe like a breath of
fresh air to them i agree with that well
okay really quick would you rather take
a time machine to the past or the future
the past
is there a specific era you'd like to
explore
maybe they're all quite interesting to
to expect yeah yeah the 1980s oh yeah
then the 1960s
um the 1950s and also the 1920s and the
1910s it's true it'd be hard to pick do
you like uh music from any of those eras
the most uh not really yeah what music
do you listen to
i listen to kylie minogue samantha jade
and natalie bassingthwaite they're all
australian pop singers oh wow yeah
that's so
specific you you mostly just listen to
those three yeah yeah wow well you
should try to get one of them on the
show i bet yeah colin minoat because i'm
a big fan of those oh okay yeah these
are great i'm i'm glad if if nothing
else comes with this podcast hopefully
it'll just lead to some some people that
you want on your show being on your show
yeah of course yeah um are you more of a
talker or a texter would you say talker
yeah yeah well you're a very good sir
you see with with texting it takes too
long i know and there's no emotion
involved i know you know what i've
gotten into michael which might be of
interest to you is um i like doing the
voice notes the that's what i did i just
did with kristin with with belle um
where you do you have that on your phone
the voice note where you hold down the
little yeah it has that on on whatsapp
and oh yeah exactly yeah i like you and
instagram as well oh yeah that's right
yeah on dms um okay are you more of a
knight or morning person that's a bit
hard to say because i'm not i'm not a
night owl and i'm not an early bird
either oh okay you're like a midday
person yeah yeah a noon riser um
beach would you prefer the beach or the
mountains
beach
do you have any preference of the toilet
roll being over or the toilet roll under
over over yeah me too is it true that
the in australia the
toilets flush the opposite way that they
do here um
i'm not too sure how the toilet how the
toilet's flush in america but in
australia it just
um i think swirls yeah our swirls too um
and i know there are a lot of like uh
dangerous exotic animals in australia do
you live near any like
spiders or snakes that could harm you
um not in my area no but um we do get um
huntsman's oh those are the huge spiders
i'm scared of them yeah yeah my um and
we also have red backs and also white
tips and funnel web spiders oh those are
gnarly
oh yeah yeah do you ever encounter
no i stay away from them because i'm
terrified of spiders oh money large
any large hairy ones even tarantulas yes
i hate tarantulas
constantly too many eyes and legs
yes
michael's making
a very expressive disgusted face
the last thing is if you would do me a
favor and finish this sentence
life is short so
make the most of it yes i love that
michael well god you you really seem
like you are making the most of it i i
mean that you seem like you were um you
to me you're just really doing such good
things for the world and um thanks and
and i i can't tell you what a pleasure
this was for me it was really nice to
get to meet you likewise justin i'd also
like to um say this um if you're if
you're at all interested in being
friends that's completely fine with me
oh hey it's likewise it's fine with me i
feel like we are friends oh excellent
that would be great and
also i gotta tell you this yeah what do
you think of what do you think of this
scenario
i'm in some kind of competition
and i end up winning for some reason but
but another person who really wanted to
win and it was and the award was a
trophy or a medal i would actually say
to that person who really wanted to win
so badly and was very crushed when they
when he or she didn't i would say
don't worry about it because
i i secretly knew how much you wanted to
win so i had the award engraved in your
name
what do i think of that i think it would
be a really
like lovely selfless act i think it
would be such a
is my as my greatest act of kindness yes
it would be a very it would be a truly
kind act and if and if the person asked
me why did you do this yeah i would say
hopefully the world will learn something
from this well i think that would be i
think you're right i mean you said it
best it would be
a really great example for the world
exactly i i like that you
think of those things i like that you
think of those
scenarios of kindness because after all
the world needs has a lot to learn about
kindness my father always taught me how
to always raise me to be a gentleman
well he's done a really wonderful job
because i would say certainly has yeah
he both of your parents have just done
such a great job um i please send them
my best please tell them how much i
enjoy watching them on the show and and
your whole family your whole dynamic
with them is it's really talk about like
an example for the world um
you guys are that i think yeah my
parents say they did their best i think
they did more than their best i agree
with you i'm grateful to them and i
think again like i i'm so appreciative
of you for being that in the world for
just your presence
yeah i know i've even said to them a few
times you two are the best parents a man
could hope for oh
man they must really that must make them
emotional
yeah
it makes them feel proud you have such a
good example of what love
is you know so yeah i'm i'm excited for
you to find that uh out in the world
thanks justin thank you so much michael
um it's my my pleasure justin i really
enjoyed this so did i so did i and give
my best to everybody and
your family and brianna and everybody
i give you all the best to to you and
your family as well
thank you i will pass it along
[Music]
so that just happened yes it's very yes
yes is more new zealand i guess but
like you said efficient it's impressive
you didn't repeat his accent back to him
i know i know how much you like that
australian accent you know what's funny
i wasn't tempted to this time because i
really wanted to be
michael is so pure in how he
communicates that i didn't want anything
like that to get in the way i didn't
want to um throw us off course
at all there's something very honest
about him and
when you're in a rhythm with somebody
like that um
i i just wanted to make sure i stayed in
there i didn't throw anything yeah and
at the risk of sounding too repetitive
i'm sure we're gonna use this word over
and over again but
it really is
the word for him i think is honest he's
honest yes yeah yeah because that
that kind of informs everything he's
honest and that leads to a certain
directness that he has
and if there's a question that he
doesn't have a clear answer for
he's honest about not kind of fudging it
and faking it he there he's virgin
virgin yeah he's just very
like real i know well that was what was
so compelling and relatable about the
show itself and to witness people who
are so honest and um
unconcerned with like
more superfluous things about
human interaction do you know does that
make sense like they i they don't
there's not a lot of performance
happening with with people that honest
they're just they say what is on their
mind they say what they feel and um it
can be
really heartbreaking it can be
very it can be inspiring too to like
there's something about it that um it's
refreshing it is and it makes you and
then when you do find that in your own
life someone you can be honest with and
and you can have that connection with uh
while being so honest there's something
really like romantic about that
potential i found and
there's the end of the first season um
is one of the most romantic episodes
don't give it away i won't but like
there is
you know some of the characters do find
like a real
wonderful love he he has such a
wonderful cadence too and when he talks
oh i know it's almost like he's telling
a group of people a story yes like write
it down now i'm going to describe
something uh-huh yeah and there's
something a little like slightly almost
conspiratorial
yeah it's really engaging it's like and
even if it's
something that you i might consider like
mundane not mundane but just you know
not as um dramatic
he'll he'll set it up in a dramatic way
oh i could have listened to it first of
all it was the whole thing i felt like i
was getting this great bonus episode of
love on the spectrum because when that
show is over yeah if you want more so
disappointing because it's like i can't
wait for season three i just want more
and more so this felt like a fun
bonus episode in general but um
but like
because he's the same with he was almost
the same with you as he was on the show
which
which tells me yeah that that's really
his him you know yeah like if you talk
to a contestant on the bachelor let's
say
i could almost guarantee you
the way they talk to you on this show
would be quite different than how they
come across yeah on camera right well
that's again like not too late for the
point but that's what was refreshing
about seeing
people like michael go on dates was
because they were unfiltered there was
something very
real about them it's so much more real
we're so used to i'm so used to reality
tv dating shows in particular being
now so performative and we talk about it
a lot but it really when you watch love
in the spectrum you realize just how far
off the rails
those day most of those dating shows are
which is there's just like somebody
trying to like
entertain and be famous and
you know be charming whatever but
michael's charm is that he is i mean
it's it's comes from a very real place
and and not trying to be charming
he's a gentleman absolutely presents
himself in a like formal gentlemanly way
but his real charm is uh something he's
i think maybe
even unaware of which is the best and
like you said even the mundane stuff was
enjoyable i could have listened to
an hour of you guys talking about
hankies and
body hair oh i know it's like
that was that to me was hankies was kind
of the most enjoyable part of the whole
thing you know just very mundane
conversations and his perspective
because he has
such a unique
point of view and very strong point of
view yes unique and strong when he when
he feels something he he's he just
answers it very with conviction it's
funny how he's very serious obviously
but he loves comedy i know and i know he
he's not a laugher obviously you but you
finally got him to laugh at one point do
you remember
no you were talking about the sandwich
that he would have
that he'd create based on his name
and it was when you said well you know
what if if i
if i'm eating that sound or the salami
and
you said you said i'm gonna if anyone
asked me i'm gonna tell them i'm eating
michael theo and he chuckled oh see and
i was like yeah yes well i victory sure
i did too at the time because i
i'm that's why i'm a good match for
somebody like that because i get e i
want i need the laugh yes and that's why
his relationship with his mom is so
fantastic
you're right such a great laugher right
they're such a fun i know odd couple
pairing it's like groucho marx and
margaret dumont like he is such a good
straight man to her
jokester she's she is
i mean i want to be i want to like be in
the family i want to like be family
friends well you're friends with him now
i am i actually i was
so sweet i know that he made a formal i
mean again he's a very formal person so
he made a formal
request yeah to be friends i loved it
like when does that happen i know i know
it should happen more often it should
and and but it's but it's for clarity's
sake you know that's
he's like i don't want to mince with
yeah like i mean obviously it was going
in that direction and i'm sure he felt
that you felt it you were getting along
very well yeah
but to be very clear right he asked you
directly directly yeah honestly if you'd
want to be his friend yeah i really
appreciated that yeah and the thing that
was lost in the podcast with somebody
like michael he has such an expressive
face he was talking about his mother's
expressive face but he he makes such
strong expressions and again if you
watch the show you know but he was doing
that throughout the zoom and it was
really charming and like entertaining to
me i'm sure he has very like i can't
wait to see the screenshots yes he is
he's as clear in his expressions as he
is with his answers the kristen bell
stuff was amazing oh man and you know
what i knew kristen would know him and
love him oh she does oh yeah well you
know what i'll play it for maybe maybe
for the voice memo oh she responded
almost right away oh wow yes she she
adores him and i love that one of the
things he likes about her is that she
has the same height
no i know so so funny
she does have a great height i do i
agree with him i think one of my
favorite parts of the whole thing was
every time you guys interrupt each other
oh man you were you to him yeah it was
like a deferential off it was so funny
because he has it was so telling of his
personality because every time it
happened
he was so respectful i know of the
interruption and of his role in the
interruption i know and he would
apologize and you'd say i'm sorry i
interrupted you instead of just kind of
like battling for who's going to say
something next you know like like a lot
of people a lot of people yeah i mean
maybe most most people i know that's
true he's also very respectful of the
lgbtq community how big was that flag i
was curious it was um
it was about this way it was a couple
inches it was a couple inches it was a
little minifl it was like the minions
flat no you reach off camera yeah it was
right there it wasn't in the background
no it must have been in a little i
imagine it was in like a cup with a
bunch of pens and stuff you know it was
like that size but the reveal again this
is when i wish it was a visual medium
because the reveal
of the lg the pride flag was
one of the funniest things and it
totally took me by surprise because he
was like and and again like he said
serious he was serious like and this is
like i would show jim this and it was
just like a flat like a little pride
flag came into view and i was like oh
well
he had it at the ready yeah you didn't
have one
but it comparatively makes you feel i
know like like you're not like i'm a
homophobe
cause i don't even have uh
i know i don't i should get one uh
listeners might not have realized this
until he he said how old he was
um because he comes across
much
older much more mature than he is
he's 27 years old but he
crazy it's crazy
because not only does he present in a
very mature way but
he seems
pretty fixated on the idea of
being old i know you know
and to me
27 year old
man is like oh you're just starting out
i know you know the whole world is in
front of you oh i think when i was 27 i
like i was
so unformed and yeah you know eager and
like kind of bouncing all over the place
he just seems so kind of like he knows
what he wants he's really into dates he
knew when you were born
whenever on the show if you watch the
show he always asks whoever he's on a
date with what year they're born and he
compares ages and he's really but again
he does it in a very respectful way like
everything he does he's not respectful
yeah oh i'm sorry uh he's yeah i'd like
to i have a question for you i'd like to
ask and like yeah okay the the most here
were you born the curious thing about
him though is
he so clearly wants to find love and
have
companionship and all that
but
he
at the same time i know you were trying
to get at this with him yeah i didn't
there's no way there's no way and
probably for him there's no way to quite
explain such a desire in a way that
would be satisfying but to me he seems
like such an interesting
curious guy who has all these hobbies
and passions and interests that he seems
i mean of course everyone
likes the idea of
you know meeting a partner that's that's
pretty universal i think but in his case
he seems
to have more
individual
you know hobbies and interests that
would occupy his mind like he's a good
single more than most people yeah i know
exactly but single person but i guess
philosophically it's like if you don't
know something if you don't have
experience with something like i
i had had by the time i was 27 they
weren't good relations i wouldn't say
they were like healthy related but i i
had had relationships
and
so i could make
a more informed
decision as to whether or not i wanted
one
full-time you know if i wanted like how
how i wanted that to fit into my life
but if you
have yet to have like a real
you know relationship right that is a
different context it is like how would
you know but i guess
i i i'm sure he would say something like
well in its best form in like a
relationship in the the truest sense in
in the best sense like a best friend and
also obviously we've only gotten a
relatively small window into it right
his family life but in that small window
i think it's pretty clear
that his parents have a great
relationship and they like each other a
lot yeah so if that's his primary
you know inspiration for relationships
then
it makes sense that he would want one so
badly because oh yeah that's what he's
seen growing up oh for sure yeah i'd
love to go to australia and hang out oh
my god you know how fun would that be so
fun and what a great family so uh again
if you haven't seen the show definitely
check out and check out michael's uh
podcast mr plus yeah um let's read a
letter okay your printer is broken so i
sent this to you yes so you won't be
hearing the uh traditional crinkling of
the paper
i'm gonna miss that well maybe next week
okay uh from kelly maudlin subject
garfield exclusive discovery uh i just
wanted to point this out i'm baffled
that you guys didn't even mention this
uh-oh this
sounds a little shamey it's a shame
[ __ ] i like a good treat well because
you know it you you that you have a
history with it it was a shame yeah i
sure do it's in your blood in my dna yes
here we go so this might uh this might
scratch your little itch
um and then she has she said i'm baffled
that you guys didn't even mention this
and then a head explode emoji which i
use a lot actually the fact that you
guys have the audacity whoa
oh
to sit there and not acknowledge that
christian is in fact the voice of
garfield
the audacity huh and then a laffy to the
side cry laughs you sound like garfield
a little bit christian i feel like
garfield right now i guess you do
christians calm
slowed voice
is
spot on huh
i haven't heard garfield in a while yeah
i mean i i remember he was a little john
and odie is annoying is this an insult
um or a compliment i oh i don't know i
always like what bill murray played him
in the movie it's kind of cool
okay yeah that's true um
i was back to
kelly i was dying when i realized it
which was almost immediately no worries
i came to at pepe
and played it back
no worries i came to you at pepe
and played it back i was referencing a
conversation we had that
neither of us remember
kids were old yes
senile and then she gave like a wacky
like a crazy a tongue-out face so i'm
just listening in imagining you're
having this talk slash debate with the
[ __ ] garfield himself
slowly tapping and swatting your cup of
coffee off of the edge and batting his
abusive little pause at the microphone
that's christian's christian doing a
garfield what kelly imagines you guys
are fantastic
[ __ ] love this podcast [ __ ] thank
you kelly thank you kelly
thank you kelly
i still prefer her to nermal i don't
know if i would and this is just maybe
me defending garfield wait there's more
sound like garfield oh really thanks for
what you do
black
heart the amount of content you put out
there is really impressive
in sheer minutes
it's
and it's greatly appreciated that's nice
thank you kelly uh nice letter well as i
was timid for me as i was saying
i might just be defending garfield
because apparently i sound like him but
i don't know if i would call garfield an
[ __ ]
um garfield's pretty abusive he's lazy
he's moody
he's kind of an [ __ ] he is yeah you
should read him again cause i was
reading him to uh our nephew recently
and i was like it when you see it
through the the lens of a like pure like
sweet three-year-old and
just some of the stuff that garfield
does i mean he
is more like cynical and lazy she is
cynical and lazy but john for example
qualities i identify with yeah well
maybe that's how kelly meant that's what
she meant was to identify you with those
specific qualities and not the [ __ ]
part right but like john
john like waits on him hand and foot
john's like so patient with him he well
he's a human and that's his pets i know
but like and then garfield will swat was
just like he like scratches the [ __ ] out
of odi i mean i guess it's been a while
he like kicks normal he like punts odie
he like punts them well you're odie well
no that's no we've talked about that we
have but there's definitely odie here's
a good would you rather would you rather
be compared to odie i mean because she
was not only was she comparing you to
him she was like i am him yeah she was
like
i'm he yeah you're a he
is garfield he him
oh that's a good question i don't know
um i think it's i think garfield's a he
i think so odie is yeah but would you
rather be compared like that the way
kelly did to garfield or odie just voice
wise no personality-wise she didn't
compare my personality i guess she's my
voice odie doesn't have a voice right
no he's like i mean he does a lot of
like dog oh my god you're so ody yeah
okay wait i just want to see what she
says about this asphalt part
um so i'm just listening imagining
you're having this tox debate with the
[ __ ] garfield himself himself
um yeah she says your voice is spot on
that's true
that's not bad no no i think he's got
kind of a cool voice kind of like an h
john benjamin e voice yeah yeah um
and iconic all right thanks for the
compliment kelly all right so what do
you think of when you hear the name
kelly kelly bundy kelly aunt martin
kelly
uh kapowski
kelly i'm not asking you to name every
kelly no no but i was just saying what
i'm thinking oh really but what's the
first one
i guess kelly kapowski oh really
what's yours kelly taylor who's that
90210 oh yeah i wasn't a big number two
jenny garth yeah uh we were talking
about that recently because we had um
christian and i were reminiscing about a
dinner that we went to we attended in
vegas with
jenny garth and peter fetchinelli mm-hmm
that's right
and chris knows well a few few uh
current names you just dropped yeah but
uh our friend kier for the record we
didn't know chris knowth we didn't know
beforehand we didn't know them and he
just happened to be at this big dinner
yeah i probably shouldn't have mentioned
him so uh we can cut that out i don't
know if i appreciate the association
right now
the hell
uh it depends on what when people are
listening to this
oh that's true uh but our friend kier at
the dinner
shout out i hope he's listening
he uh
peter chanelli was like we were talking
to him for a while and you know it was
vegas we were having some drinks and um
and kier afterwards was like so is that
guy like a race car driver
i love care and i love that story but i
think that falls in the category of who
cares that's true we should cut all this
out oh maybe not this is kind of fun uh
if you guys would like to write into the
show
like kelly did our email address is life
is short at wondery.com and thanks again
to
the charming delightful
honest yeah michael theo yeah and
everyone go check out his podcast and
his show love on the spectrum two
seasons i also thought uh kelly lynch
and
kelly um uh kelly preston yeah really
sad you know a lot of kelly's
so um
thanks to all the kelly's listening and
and uh all the michaels and
everyone and to the whole theo family
yes you guys are the best and uh thanks
for everything thank you all talk to you
next week bye
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
a life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian law also produced by megan v
monaco and katie the allen senior
producer on this michelle mish lambs and
the audio engineer sergio enriquez and
the executive producer
marshall louie and the company for which
we all do it let me do my best garfield
hello justin um i just got your message
and i would like you to play this for
michael michael what a joy it was to
hear your voice
um thank you for the compliments i think
you are also a light in this world um i
love watching you on the television um i
wish you the absolute best of luck with
your new show
i will absolutely be watching and i hope
that you have a spectacular holiday love
kristen
you